the head of the United Nations
International atomic energy agency has
arrived to Vienna following his visit to
Ukraine's besieged zepparisian nuclear
power plant and had this to say I was
able to see myself and my team impact
holes
markings on on buildings of um
so which means that the physical
Integrity of the facility has been
violated not once but several several
times Raphael Grossi flatly denied that
Russia who occupied the power plant
denied him the right to move freely
saying he was given full access by the
Russians to the site and was able to
inspect everything he requested to see
he also confirmed his agency would keep
two staff members at the plant
permanently and that the iaea would
issue a full report in the next week on
their findings earlier on Friday Moscow
again accused Ukraine of shelling the
power plant but reserved judgment on the
iaea mission
we positively view the fact that despite
all problems and difficulties caused by
the Ukrainian side's provocative actions
the mission has reached the site and
started work you're aware that the team
will stay at the site and continue
working that's why it's still too early
to assess it but what's most important
is that the mission is there the mission
is expected to assess the plant's
condition and nuclear security Ukraine
contended the visit was staged managed
by Russia Kiev accused Russia of
intimidating Ukrainian nuclear plant
workers iaea inspectors were accompanied
by a man in a suit later identified as a
Russian advisor to rostaton the Russian
nuclear agency that's further evidence
for ukrainians that the inspectors were
not able to work freely at the plant
without Russian interference as Grossi
suggested in his press conference
demolatorization of the territory of the
station is the goal and it is bad that
we have not yet heard the appropriate
messages from the iaea despite the fact
that we talked about it with Mr Grossi
during our meeting in Kiev it was the
key security point of our agreements it
was outlined clearly demilitarization
and full control by our nuclear workers
it's clear Ukraine wants the nuclear
power plant to be demilitarized and
Russian troops to leave immediately but
the iaea doesn't even have the means to
enforce that it also doesn't have the
mandate to determine who's responsible
for the shelling it's a complicated
situation and very volatile and changing
seemingly not day by day but hour by
hour
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Keith